[Aplausos]
voy a pedirles que hagan un ejercicio de
memoria
que se traslada en el domingo pasado
tres días más
y piensen el domingo en la tarde
el desasosiego del domingo en la tarde
el aburrimiento del domingo en la tarde
quien ha sentido ese aburrimiento ese
desasosiego levanten la mano
menos mal nos encontramos ahora porque
hace un tiempo
yo les decía cambien de trabajo
el síndrome de la tarde del domingo se
combate con cambiar del trabajo
ahora le digo a la gente cambie su
trabajo
porque que nos ha pasado el trabajo ha
perdido sentido
hemos deshumanizado nuestros trabajos
hemos separado lo económico de lo social
de lo que nos conecta con otros
y esa conexión es la que genera
entusiasmo sin esa conexión el lunes por
la mañana el domingo por la noche son
una desgracia
entonces
yo los invito a pensar en cómo integrar
a su trabajo
fines sociales cualquiera que sea el
trabajo y hacerlo va a humanizar ese
trabajo
quiero empezar con una historia
que muchos podrán conocer pero no todos
y es una historia que arranca en el 74
con un economista
en bangladesh en una universidad y el
estar rodeado
de gente que no tiene insumos para
ponerse a trabajar
hay hambruna alrededor y sin esos
insumos él se ve presionado a intervenir
y él dice
cuenta la leyenda que sacó de su
billetera 27 dólares y se lo repartió a
42 familias y arranco
una revolución que hoy en día entendemos
como la revolución de las microfinanzas
el impulso aunque llevaba
lo llevó a crear el grammy y bng
en bengalí ramin quiere decir aldea el
banco de la aldea
hoy ese banco tiene cerca de 8 millones
y medio de socias
hoy mohamed yunus ha contado esta
historia y ha recorrido el mundo entero
buscando que aquel que no tiene la
oportunidad porque no tiene los recursos
económicos la encuentra que aquel que
está siendo excluido de
los circuitos económicos pueda volver a
ser incluido
y mohamed yunus por haber hecho eso el
impacto social que ha tenido eso ha
logrado
y la banca tradicional le ponga atención
a aquellos que no les ponía atención
antes
que la banca tradicional haya
descubierto que la gente sin recursos es
buena paga
y
con el tiempo el reconocimiento
universal que recibió yunus lo hizo con
el grammy embargo merecedor del premio
nobel de la paz no el premio nobel de
economía el premio nobel de la paz
entonces
tremenda historia pero hay un detalle
que me entristece
y es que en 1911
63 años antes
había un padre llamado el padre de
campoamor que hacía eso
ofrecía microcrédito creó un círculo de
obreros con el tiempo esto se convierte
en el banco caja social el banco caja
social hoy en día tiene 3 millones de
clientes activos porque porque se
necesita acceso a crédito
el banco de caja social es una
institución aquí en colombia así como la
fundación social la fundación social es
esta fundación que usa herramientas
empresariales como el banco cada social
es una empresa de las varias que
dependen de la fundación y la fundación
es una fundación con empresas no una
empresa con fundación es muy distinto
pero
esa combinación es la que no sólo a
través del banco y a través de la
fundación ha hecho a los jesuitas los
jesuitas también lograban desarrollo y
paz lograban generar valor para la
sociedad
mientras generaban valor económico a los
padres cuando iban a una parroquia en
santander les decían usted no solo va a
realizar usted tiene que darle vida a
una cooperativa de crédito y ahorros y
usted tiene que crear una institución
educativa imagínense las palancas que
tenían el evangelio la educación y la
economía
pues nosotros tenemos que generar valor
económico pero a la vez generar valor
social cuando los dos se juntan es
poderosísimo
esto es otra alternativa y también lo
hace la fundación social la intervención
directa
proyectos sociales
pero la diferencia entre esta
alternativa y la anterior es que aquí yo
necesito tener los recursos económicos
para invertir selo a generar valor para
la sociedad a generar inclusión mientras
que en la anterior yo en la misma
operación empresarial generó la
transformación para la sociedad
lo triste
es que esta opción es la común cuando yo
sigo generando utilidades pero destruyó
valor para la sociedad yo sigo generando
utilidades pero contaminó
una empresa que contamina una empresa
que discrimina pero sigue generando
utilidades
nos genera problemas una empresa en el
sector de alimentos que ofrece alimentos
poco saludables y gana mucho dinero y
sigue haciendo eso pues genera poco
bienestar en la sociedad ese camino
no está excusado porque yo entonces
genere una fundación y genere valor para
la sociedad por otro lado y entonces
aquí uno ve que el que peca y reza
empata pues no eso no se da como así lo
que necesitamos es la conjunción entre
la generación de valor económico con
transformaciones sociales
y eso
es posible para todos nosotros no tiene
uno que estar en el nivel directivo en
que es más fácil de estar uno en el
nivel directivo y decidir
también se puede hacer desde niveles
intermedios y uno convence al de arriba
convence al de abajo convence a los de
alrededor o si uno no está en una
organización uno puede crear su propio
emprendimiento
hoy en día enseñamos procesos
emprendedores en las universidades
porque entendimos cómo se hace eso
entonces
es posible
y eso son el camino que ha recorrido
organizaciones como la organización
corona cuando ellos responden a algo que
todos sentimos a quien no le gusta tener
su casa bonita
a todos nos gusta pero hay gente que no
puede aquí me gritan y la cocina
y el baño
y si yo no puedo
y soy una empresa de construcción
y estoy dando elementos para esas casas
porque no busco la forma de hacer que
aquellos que tienen el paquete de
cemento puedan poner un día un poco de
cerámica un poco enchape aquí y allá y
tener casas cocinas baños que sean más
fácil de limpiar y que le generen a uno
una sensación de orgullo
entonces esto que no es fácil a corona
le costó mucho trabajo encontrar la
forma de hacerlo porque tenía que vender
puerta a puerta cuando yo tengo mi
cocina empaquetada en cemento por lo
general voy a los centros comerciales a
ver no a comprar
y no tengo tarjeta de crédito
no tengo en efectivo entonces me tienen
que dar crédito y me tienen que llevar
el producto a la casa
esa entrega puerta a puerta no era fácil
pero se pudo
esta historia le muestra a uno
es posible que si se puede
cuando belisario betancur
se postuló a la presidencia de colombia
en 1982 con este eslogan de campaña
logro ser elegido presidente
pasaron cuatro años
la gente empezó a hacer el balance las
promesas y realidades
mucha promesa incumplida y se le cayó la
tilde
si se puede
pero tenemos que superar el cinismo
porque este eslogan
es poderosísimo
1982 belisario lo usa después en su
quinta aspiración a ser presidente del
país 26 años después lo copia el
presidente candidato en ese entonces
barack obama yes we can
los colombianos nos adelantamos unos
cuantos años a revoluciones mundiales
pero dejemos los los grandes hitos
trabajo es el que tienen hoy en día
examinen
sus trabajos miren
qué es lo que hacen sus organizaciones y
si sus organizaciones tienen bienes o
servicios
que les sirven a la gente y no todo el
mundo tiene acceso a esos servicios por
favor busquen cómo hacer lo posible
porque sí se puede no es fácil no
necesitan la energía ni el carisma de
yunus pero es posible
y el si se puede dejar de ser
un eslogan de campaña y se convierte en
un grito de batalla muchas gracias
[Aplausos]